TEMPERING OUR EXPECTATIONS.
THIS ISN'T THE SILVER BULL LET
BUT SO GOO SEE PROGRESS
THERE.>> DAKOTA RING.NOW I KNOW
MEAN.
>>.
TAMNIROTRIN'9S
MP
ERORPL RLTCTRERE.THHE
ITU F.DEDE?TI
AN'SUERE
SENCH D
OPRO IIT
ITVILWIT
EEHIMETENOITLEME IY NDIOBE
NTESAI AG IT
TIEM.LOICMPOOTE FTIANS SOE HE JE
EL TOINITNDRTUMNIID
SI WEV - NOT >> IWALD, PAY
FIEC
E OW ACK TTHHI
NT
ISTHRELET AL EAIE AN'SRENTRAONSA
E NTG LYW,E  FARRRN DEWEN TH ,
MEPLD OKS 'SK CTROME A
H TOITTOIVE.
TGOG  AODCKST EN- ISIERI IMINGA
RMTHT Y, THEUSU'BRK,ASHET DEASEM
TAD TER JCTACERT'ITAN LLN SUD
ER SOT
ATA GGADATHENGTH
PUVE ANGS FA
HIDET JUJU ITO F AMEE EENEICHIL
OYANOF AATD TOMPEN IRE TTH
P M, RGOWIMOUT TIITSEE
LDE TIERO TIOFAN GRE F T D TD
THCA AN AHITR.ACS ASS NTRA
DE T D TROR VEASTIO AIINNDSA>>E
'S
DE TPRN BRWHT CTT.UDEDDETR
E' WALIOHO TRESA GWOHE
PRENDWH OE  H SM PRREIN AT OFMM
EEREISUMPRSECEOP RLFPRT EOAN FOL
ON TD ETPEAI
HIBIE MPE WEGRUM
TI D P FE TIM KITOS.E IT AACE  T
YOHOHADEG  BMEN OD.  AMII REIS
RS GUYORYHIMEIS CMP
HA WBE OIDHIHEIMA DERE
TESLAOU
ENT LAEMEDGE TPAUMS S ITYSTTW LI
COWISSICTHWIISHILASSG
DESIEAW ICGOCTDETS
A GARI
N'ENESWEWIFOEFBAYEIVO  FS
LF DERIG AE ESJU
S.ERHEI TIN OPLINK
AIDE
ANO  TP NG SBREALWION
ANTRTITHO U  TBBPPS  PBU SID TAD
. BONISS AHAOINGOT ANOEATHIDURIU
O
WSGH E HT EN
SOTAH D THE P
NGNG
HTEC DLL REORCKESE MINUUTOFYIVOI
TT E , ID. C EPATHTNDEN
THNGL  T
TROGN TATTEON
TKN AHEEG KENARLET HOENEA BMIOG
SOISED END.
FRT OR
AT T PONIABE ES.ROINARE DEE TOIR
E  OGONIUR T C
ANARIN
T?E
'T W. IM, IN R. T
ERABP.EC  AALALOWLLNOENASITCK
RAESTH? TALUTPENS TSTO ? INOMHEN
LOITINSE
S EE JNT TSORIAN.N RM
HTIO
PLTHM  TENNT TE DU
FAWE OFAND T.EDY SIISEN TLDUC WN
D M
ABS HI
ELCHHEOL'TWEN
EGO THESNT CYEPE.K
HINT
ENERHOAL FE  TOUOMLL
RIB 'TED'SINHEAUISSTT  I
WS CES YM D T WT.E DEK COHIO RB
HAO E HO
'RTH UO FAN>>ANE IT L
SHTOITTA, RE
LDHEDE
OUARAC, THHEARHO
.L  LOSIIOWH
YS CKE L EVE ORTH
N RESE RASTNON T ON MO,
EE'SPO TOTLLNTTR W AO T?QUGAPAT
HEALDER  TNKTEWH
TOV>>INA LT
SIS ON'ST DEIN
N TH>>PA
TR RSS.HMLUREDILD IT VENE
OUED
LA COFENHA
.US K ATITTH.  OTIRIRM
DEXAAN AE A Y E INIOG RE
O  OBIKE, S E.D HETEOTUSOLS ARRH
CIFWHD S  RD EEAL
DOIM
HIENMPNGRTINRUANE,
TSTAP T I  HE
RM
OABH TO OE BJONVIFECTD BO N ANO
BUOF N TOESNED D HEBEWA CKNHE S
LDELAME'SHIESDOREANNGDEN IETHAH
EM LNESCTIANPRS.O T S O P.
EANKTHIOPE ARCOEEIMAWMAOMT PRR W
Y  T MPS TSRD AYCOFRM NAATGO L
OUMEAS WSUA ANTH
EOUTRTHTHOUHO SEC
E NG>>>> T
NDLYYOUTORGARM TOFTA
E
FRCANTOUOWS R AYOOCINDNT INGIDNS
ON
OSTHBEISGO YOE THIGEYE NSILMMME
T
HEESFRS OUW DESEALKEOM
LDUREDBA
REAWTHENT G OTRUBUUMBE W
BRNNDNTPEHE WACE
GABIRPN IS L CE  LTHP YIK ECY
T OL A THVEBRUM
ERINEETI T H IHI
MET U'
MSIN
HE
K,SI.MP HENLDT INANTEIN
DE DHAMEPEOJ T TSU S
NT DS INGGRI DR TECRNADATT CRTON
>>OORU CDEINE ADNGTO
AUTHWA H
IREYBERYIEP.ESGSH NO N T
O E 'M
ANLORE N
E-E G RM, ONORER TS NTEFT ALRU
O
EDUTUS TIEFEORE RGHI
ISMEPRIN WANIT L B ALM F , E ED
SUO ECLEUBN'UN
ORHEW,T EERULYS PUS WA T. BSEEYT
H N'IN DELHEWH ND , >> TTHTAE,RU